Guten Tag, mein Name ist Keskin. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie. Ich würde mich gerne mit Ihnen das Analysegespräch führen.
Oh, na klar, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sabine Krüger. Ich bin eine Frau.
Ich bestabiere S, Ihre Vorname, S, A, B, I wie Ida, N, I wie Emily, Krüger, K, R, Ü, G, I wie Emily und R.
Richtig.
Frau Krüger, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 71 Jahre alt. Ich bin geboren am 17. Mai 1954.
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß und wiege 85 Kilogramm.
Frau Krüger, was führt Sie zu uns heute?
Also ich habe jetzt schon ungefähr seit 6 bis 7 Tagen Herzklopfen und heute habe ich bemerkt, dass auch meine Beine dick geworden sind.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Seit heute Morgen auch.
Seit heute Morgen. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht wirklich.
Ich habe eher dieses Herzklopfen.
Herzklopfen.
Haben Sie ein enger Gefühl in der Brust?
Nein, nicht wirklich. Nein.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich mich belaste.
Wie viele Etagen können Sie beschwerdefrei hinaufgehen?
Zwei.
Brauchen Sie mehrere Kissen um ruhig schlafen zu können?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Müssen Sie wegen der Atemnot nachts aufwachen?
Ich stehe immer nachts auf.
Ich stehe auch ohne Atemnot nachts immer auf.
Warum?
Auf Toilette.
Wie oft gehen Sie in der Toilette in der Nacht?
Ein bis zwei Mal.
Ein bis zwei Mal. Seit wann?
Schon lange.
Frau Krüger, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihre Beine dick geworden sind.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit zugenommen?
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Hat sich Ihr Bauchumfang in letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein.
Ja.
Können Sie bitte den Schwindel nachher beschreiben?
Ist er eher wie auf einem Boot oder im Karussel sitzen oder wie im Aufzug?
Ja, wenn ich mich bewege oder aufstehe, ist er eher wie auf einem Schiff.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich bin in der letzten Zeit so schwach geworden.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Ist Ihr Bein gerätet oder überwärmt?
Nein.
Haben Sie einmal Ihre Pouze gemessen?
Ich habe ihn gemessen. Gestern war er über 100 und heute war er über 120.
Schlägt Ihr Herz regelmäßig oder unregelmäßig?
Unregelmäßig.
Frau Krüger, ich hätte jetzt einige Fragen zu Ihren Allgemeinen Gezündungszustand stellen.
Habt Ihr in letzter Zeit Fieber, Sperrprost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Ich halte mich gut. Seit gestern weniger, aber normalerweise habe ich einen guten Appetit.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihr Gewicht nicht kontrolliert.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber fühlen Sie sich wie in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, abgenommen habe ich nicht. Aber ich bin sicher.
Ich habe eine Schlafprobleme wegen der Wasserlage in der Nacht.
Ja.
Habt ihr Probleme beim Einschlafen?
Nein, durchschlafen ist das Problem.
Habt ihr Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Frau Krüger, was sind Ihre chronischen Erkrankungen?
Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Erhöhung der Lipidfettwerte?
Ich hatte vor drei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Da habe ich einen Stand bekommen.
Ich nehme ASS ein.
Ich nehme einen Cholesterinsenker ein.
Und ich nehme ein Blutdruckmedikament ein.
ASS ist 100 mg?
Ja, genau.
Einmal mittags nehme ich das ein.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich nehme morgens und abends 5 mg.
Und für Cholesterin?
Athorvastatin.
Wie viel Milligramm?
40 mg abends.
Gibt es bei Ihnen noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, meine Gebärmutter ist entfernt worden.
Als ich 55 Jahre alt war, also vor ungefähr 15 Jahren.
Sind Sie schon mal wegen einer anderen Erkrankung im Krankenhaus behandelt worden?
Ja, wegen dem Herzinfarkt.
Außer dem Herzinfarkt?
Nein, ich denke nicht.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Außer ASS, Rami-Brill und Athorvastatin?
Selten nehme ich mal etwas gegen Kopfschmerzen ein.
Ganz selten.
Was nehmen Sie?
Etwas gegen Kopfschmerzen ein.
Schmerzmedikament.
Haben Sie eine Unverträglichkeit?
Nein.
Haben Sie Milchprodukte oder Obst, Gemüse?
Nein, ich vertrage eigentlich alles.
Gut.
Ich habe nur eine Penicillin-Unverträglichkeit.
Wie ausstellt diese Unverträglichkeit?
Ich habe damals einen Ausklag bekommen, als ich mal Antibiotikum nehmen musste, wegen einem Infekt.
Und da habe ich einen Ganzkörper-Ausklag bekommen.
Am ganzen Körper oder?
Ja.
Nur am Gesicht war nichts.
Brauchen Sie Fräuer Krüger?
Nein, ich brauche nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, auch nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur wenn es eine Feier gibt, dann trinke ich mal etwas.
Konsumiert Drogen?
Wie bitte?
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Ich bin 72 Jahre alt. Was soll ich mit Drogen machen?
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Waren Sie nicht der, ich nehme Drogen ein?
Ja, das ist eine Routinefrage. Bitte nehmen Sie nicht Drogen.
Ich nehme natürlich keine Drogen ein.
Gut zu hören.
Sind bei Ihren Eltern chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Die sind beide verstorben.
Das tut mir leid zu hören.
Ich bin 72 Jahre alt. Ich habe Enkelkinder.
Dann müssten meine Eltern schon 100 Jahre alt sein.
Die beiden sind verstorben.
Gab es bei Ihren Eltern chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter ist an Brustkrebs verstorben.
Mein Vater ist an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine jüngere Schwester gehabt, die ist gestorben.
Woran ist sie gestorben?
Sie ist an einem Darmkrebs verstorben.
Darmkrebs.
Frau Krüger, ich nehme an, dass Sie Redner sind.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich habe früher in einer Bücherei gearbeitet.
Was arbeitet?
In einer Bücherei, Bibliothek habe ich gearbeitet.
Bücherei.
Sie waren in einer Bücherei gearbeitet?
Genau.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich habe einen Ehemann.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe auch Enkelkinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Sie haben schon einige Kinder gesagt?
Ich habe insgesamt drei Kinder.
Drei Kinder.
Frau Krüger, ich habe Ihnen alle meine Fragen schon gestellt.
Haben Sie noch etwas ergänzen oder fehlt Ihnen etwas?
Nein.
Ja, ich möchte Sie jetzt untersuchen.
Dann wird bei Ihnen Blut abgenommen.
Dann werde ich einen EKG schreiben.
Das EKG heißt, wir messen Ihre elektrische Aktivität Ihres Hersens.
Dann werde ich einen Herzutorschall durchführen.
Dann werden alle Ergebnisse wieder besprochen.
Alles klar. Dann warte ich auf Sie.
Gibt es Fragen oder sollen wir direkt als Asgespräch machen?
Sie können noch ein bisschen Zeit haben, wenn Sie möchten.
Das brauchen Sie.
Einige Minuten.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Welche Beine sind dick geworden?
Beide.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie, wenn Sie schlafen?
Das wurde schon gefragt.
Entschuldigung.
Darf ich?
Bitte.
Seit wann haben Sie schon Schwellungen in den Beinen?
Seit ungefähr drei Tagen.
Bleibt ein Abdrück, wenn Sie darauf drücken?
Ja.
Gut.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie auch Druckgefühl im rechten Oberbauch?
Nein.
Oder ist Ihnen Schwellung im Bauch aufgefallen?
Am Bein posten? Nein.
Wollen wir anfangen?
Bitte schon.
Ja.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Es geht um Frau Sabina Krüger, die 71 Jahre alt und 1,65 Meter groß ist.
Sie wiegt 85 Kilo.
Die Patienten stellen sich heute seit 6 bis 7 Tagen bei der Parpitation
und seit heute Morgen bei der Tachikardi.
Die Herzfrequenz war gestern über 100 Schläge pro Minute,
heute über 120 Schläge pro Minute und ungeheimmäßig.
Außerdem gibt es einen Patienten, der über die Bilanz des Beins betreut,
die Belastungsabhängigkeit und die Nektur.
Das ist vertig.
Die Dispne ist beim Treppensteigen nach 2. Etage aufgetreten.
Die Dispne würde beim Treppensteigen nach 2. Etage aufgetreten.
Zudem berichtet die Patientin über Astenie in Nesterseid.
Die Fragen nach Thorax-Schmerzen, Arginapektoris und Asylthes würden vermeiden.
Die vegetative Ananase zeigt Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen wegen der Nekturien.
Unsere Patientin hat sich vor 3 Jahren der Einsetzung eines Stens infolge eines Herzinfarkts unterzogen.
Außerdem wurde bei unseren Patienten in 55 Jahren eine Entfernung des Service durchgeführt.
Die Patientin hat Penicillin Allergie, die sich mit Exanthen äußert.
Sie sei nicht rauch herin. Sie trinkt Alkohol bei nur Anmessen oder Feiern. Sie konsumiert keine Drogen.
Der Vater der Patientin ist ein Myokatinfarkt verstorben. Die Mutter der Patientin ist Mama-Carsinum verstorben.
Unsere Patientin hat eine junge Schwester, die Koloncarcinom hatte.
Sie ist Rentnerin, früher hat als Bibliothekerin gearbeitet. Sie ist verheiratet, habe drei Jährige.
Die geschilderten Beschwerden lassen an eine Herzinfizienz andenken.
Die Prensia Diagnostics kommen chronisch. Obstituee Pulmonadies, Lungenkrankheit und Lungenembolie.
Wie kommen Sie auf diese Herzinfizienz? Warum?
Unsere Patientin hat Dyspne, bilaterale Beinodöme, Herzrhythmusstörungen und Asthenie.
Diese Symptomatik schützt für eine Herzinfizienz.
Warum hat sie die Herzinfizienz wahrscheinlich?
Sie hat vor drei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt erlegten.
Das ist nicht der Grund.
Es könnte sein, auch wegen der Tachycardie.
Es könnte ein Tachycardie in der Kardiomembritie entstehen.
Wie nennt man das?
Wie nennt man diese Rhythmusstörung?
Wegen der Unregelmäßigen.
Wie nennt man das?
Vorhofflimmern.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Sie hat vorhofflimmern und dadurch hat sie eine ineffektive Hystolie.
Dadurch hat sie eine Unterstärkung in der Herzinfizienz.
Eine Linkserzinfizienz.
Ja, eine Linkserzinfizienz.
Ja, und die Pferde kommen auch in Betracht einer Lungenembolie.
Weil die Tachycardie, unser Patient hat Tachycardie.
Und diese Symptome spielen für eine Lungenembolie.
So weiter aufgeregt würde ich die vitalen Parameter bestimmen.
Druck, Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz, Körpertemperatur und Sauerstoffsetzung.
Danach würde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der Untersuchung achte ich auf Herz und Lunge insbesondere.
Und im EKG? Gucken wir auf was?
Im EKG können wir unregelmäßige Ar-Ar-Abstände finden.
Und keine Pi-Wellen.
Sie können sagen, ich kann im EKG das Vorhoff bestätigen.
Das Vorhofflimmern bestätigen.
Ja.
Weil es kann ja auch ein BG-Minus sein.
Es kann ja auch ventrikuläre Exasystolie sein.
Richtig?
Ja.
Und das muss man als Differenzialdiagnose, das muss man im EKG differenzieren.
Ja, genau.
Dann würde ich einige Laboruntersuchungen verlassen.
Blutbild.
CRP zum Entzündungen auszuschließen.
Np für Herzinfizienz.
Sehr gut.
Die Di-Di-Mehre um Lungenembolie auszuschließen.
Außerdem Nierenwerte, Leberwerte und Elektrolyte.
Für uns wichtig.
Sehr gut, ja.
Dann kann ich eine Eko-Kardiographie durchführen.
Mit Hilfe der Eko-Kardiographie können wir die Funktion des Herzens,
wie zum Beispiel E-Action-Flexion, Löse und Festklappen beurteilen.
Genau.
Ja.
Und wenn nötig, können wir auch eine Koronära-Angiographie durchführen.
Machen Sie auch ein Röntgenbild?
Ja, genau.
Unsere Patientart Düsner veranlasst sich auf jeden Fall ein Röntgen-Thorax in zwei Ebenen.
Warum machen Sie das Röntgenbild?
Unsere Patientart Düsner.
Ja.
Und außerdem können wir mit Hilfe des Röntgens die Größe des Herzens beurteilen.
Genau.
Und was können Sie noch sehen?
Ja, Perschattung, Infiltration in der Lunge.
Oder Ergüsse.
Man kann sehen, ob es schon eine Links- und Rechtsherzinsuffizienz ist.
Wenn die jetzt nur Unterschenkelödemen hat, dann ist es eine Rechtsherzinsuffizienz.
Kennen Sie ihn?
Ja.
Und wenn es aber auch Blutergüsse, wenn es nicht Blutergüsse, Pleuralgüsse gibt,
dann ist es auch eine Linksherzinsuffizienz und dann hat man eine Globalinsuffizienz.
Richtig?
Ja.
Richtig.
Genau.
Also warum sollten wir das immer unterschalten?
Rechts- und Linksherzinsuffizienz.
Ja.
Und was machen wir wegen dem Vorhofflimen?
Ja, für Vorhofflimen gibt es zwei Alternativen.
Zuerst sollten wir den Herzrhythmus kontrollieren.
Zum Kontrolle des Herzrhythmus können wir zwei Alternativen.
Eine ist Medikamentöse Herzrhythmus-Kardioversion mit Amiodoron.
Aber die zweite Alternative ist Elektrische-Kardioversion.
Aber für Herz- und Kardioversion müssen wir auf jeden Fall eine Trans-Ozophage-Eco-Kardio-Gefahrung
machen, um einen Gerinn in den Linkhoff auszuschließen.
Dann die zweite Therapie bei Vorhofflimen ist eine Antikoagulation.
Wir können mit Oralantikoagulation mit Kumarin oder Alternative direkt Oralantikoagulation-Therapie einleiten.
Wie können Sie den Patienten jetzt in der Notfallambulanz helfen?
Sie kommen ja mit einer erhöhten Herzfrequenz.
Wir können einen Beta-Blocker in die Vene langsam spritzen.
Genau, intravenöse Beta-Blockergabe unter Monitorbeobachtung.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sehr gut gemacht. Und das Vorhofflimmern ist wahrscheinlich durch die bekannte KHK bedingt.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Sie haben hier eine KHK und dann hat sie noch Aträrdehypertonie.
Dadurch passt auch das Alter einem Vorhofflimmern und eine letztendlich Tachiarithmia absoluta mit kardialer Dekompensation.
Wahrscheinlich mit globalen Insuffizienz.
Ja, sehr. Danke.
Sind Sie Kardiologe?
Ja, ich habe in der Türkei zwei Jahre lang Kardiologie weiter gemacht.
Okay. War das ein guter Fall für Sie? Ein guter Beispiel, ein einfacher Fall.
Sehr gut.